mais juste avant il a il ya quelque
chose pour toi tu avais tu avais émis un
souhait c'est que gilles reviennent dans
touche pas à mon poste qu'il verdez on
sait qu il aime énormément et bien
gilles verdez et là ce soir pour ton
anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gilles verdez merci d'être l'amant gilou
plaisir merci alors et isa talent rip
rémy chéri oui c'est très ému et alors
tu avais tu disais que gillett gilles te
manquer dans tpm t gilts à quelque chose
à dire à alise à ce soir je suis super
content de te voir
quand on m'a proposé de venir je voulais
te souhaiter bon anniversaire c'est
merveilleux pour moi d'être là ce soir
de te le souhaiter d'être avec la
famille vous touche vous adore je vous
regarde vous êtes magnifique cd super
émission merci me régale et encore une
fois isabelle hains que de te toucher te
voir te parler je suis ému et j'en ai
des frissons
je suis électrique les deux dédougou
great autre vie je crois alors vigiles
la question est les éclairs isa ce que
tu as envie que gilles reviennent un peu
dans l'émission auprès de toi avec moi
il faut qu'il le souhaite aussi
est ce que tu as envie manger à ce sera
un plaisir tu as vraiment je me régale
tous les jours là avec valérie avec
benjamin mais voilà c'est un c'est un
plaisir ça fait des années que je suis à
vos côtés donc c'est quand vous voulez
je pense que le changement quant aux
dates à des salons bazin j'ai honte
d'être avec jury il manque évidemment la
semaine eric moi j'allais avec moi donc
je suis absolument ravi mais il manque
ici at mp bien sûr michelle et moi aussi
parce qu'elle a toujours des petits sont
parfois trop tronchet
mais voilà je me disais c'est
excessivement que gilles dans tes pump
et dites-nous chez vous aussi et qui moi
il me manque pendant et avant parce
qu'avant elle m'apaise beaucoup il est
très bon conseil et moi j'adore j'ai
c'est vrai qu'on peut et il n'a pas
l'air comme ça mais il est très apaisé
c'est un baume apaisant et celle inverse
de ce qu il est parfois l'organiser coup
d'essayer de vous mais en plus vous ne
jouez pas un rôle non pas du tout mais
je m'égare tout seul tu alors je
regardais les débats sur rouen j'étais
là bas je m'énerve tout seul on nous
cache des choses là je suis comme je
suis je suis comme ça oui des complots
partout ce jeu voit des complots là où
il y en a pas parce qu'il y en a
moi je peux déjà plus et m'as tu es
vraiment une maman pendant l'émission et
pas que après l'émission aussi j'ai
vraiment découvert quelqu'un les deux
dernières années ce qu'au début on
s'accrochait beaucoup c'est quelqu'un on
se parle beaucoup au téléphone on est
rentrés souvent en voiture c'est
quelqu'un d'exquis charmant très adroit
c'est un amour l honnête et c'est une
très belle personne
c'est vrai que j'ai eu c'est vrai que
c'est une très belle personne et la voix
isabelle on l'a déjà répondent à gilles
toi aussi tu es il te manque avant lui
alors je reconnais que dès qu'on parle
politique en dispute un robot et moi
j'adore gilles il te manque vraiment ah
oui moi j'y lis manque beaucoup oui mon
ami maxime hâtivement cousseau
effectivement tu laisse personne
indifférent tu es devenu un vrai ami un
lacet des animaux à des robots part
peut-être partira en vacances peut-être
ensemble on attendait 4,2 il ya deux a
fondu et c'est vrai tu es tu et des
arguments percutants et tué un homme au
grand coeur et venir oui bien sûr c'est
un très bon camarade lille est très
sincère très bienveillant il bosse
beaucoup pour un jour me l'info ou des
vraies j'aime ce côté électron libre
c'est à dire qu'il va y les poils à
gratter il va jamais dans le sens du
vent et ça j'apprécie particulièrement
il nous manque et les beurs elektron oui
il faut il faut absolument que j'y
revienne parce que c'est plus de 1000
émission j'ai lu r d ici c'est l'adn tp
c'est quelqu'un que je regardais mois
dans les émissions alors on va pas
mentir aux gens on s'accrochait c'est du
passé on en parle plus la dernière
j'étais fatigué série la vie tient pas
cru si on a eu des mots n'accrochaient
donc mais ça on le met de côté il a
totalement sa place ici en tant que
chroniqueur et je vais vous dire moi je
suis j'ai envie que gilles verdez
reviennent dans l'émission absolument je
l'embrassé
d'amour ce soit l entraide
téléspectateurs c'est que tu regarde
souvent l'émission est ce que gilles
verdez parce qu'il a souhaité critique
exagère un peu oui mais ce que l'on sait
on sait que c'est un peu c'est un peu un
jeu aussi non gelée alors c'est sûr que
c'est pas un jeu c'est ça prend la peine
lors il a un bon fond ah ouais c'est ce
qui te manque de rémission toi ballon je
regarde c'est vrai que maintenant il n'y
a plus personne qui s'énerve comme lui
bassett manque un vrai que oui m'énerve
il m'énerve un peu mais c'est vrai que
c'est drôle voilà que quelquefois il dit
des conneries quoi bon assez sur wii ça
c'est le talgo et oui c'est laisser
toujours il est toujours contre la
contre tout le monde c'est vrai alors je
t'attends tu as envie de revenir un peu
avec nous vous savez que c'est un
bonheur sur ce que je t'ai jamais lâché
je sais c'est vrai on s'écrit tout le
temps vous avez de la radio-télé les
émissions dans lequel il s'est passé
c'est que je suis toujours producteur
d'émissions dans les cas liés
et pourquoi je suis là bas je vous dirai
pas ce que je joue voilà j'écoute
beaucoup les téléspectateurs je dis la
vérité
franchement je dis tout dit et sur les
réseaux sociaux sur des gens qui me
disaient ils disaient avec gilles il a
tendance un peu trop à trop girly un
moment et c'est vrai que cyril voilà on
s'engueule trop dans l'émission on
aimerait vraiment que ce soit un peu
plus apaisé
ce que tu disais tout à l'heure sur the
voice est vrai qu'on est dans une année
dans un truc en ce moment où elle vous
le voyez depuis le début d'année
dentiste à mon poste on est un truc ou
non on pense qu à rigoler qu'à s'amuser
on n'est pas du tout on n'est plus dans
la polémique on n'est plus là dedans
c'est voilà un moment c'est vrai qu'on a
pu dériver vers ça là aujourd'hui on est
plus la demande a juste envie de se
marrer entre potes avec vous qui fait
partie de la famille des missions n'a
jamais aussi bien marché que cette année
je pense que c'est pour ça aussi et
c'est vrai que j'ai écouté les
téléspectateurs et gilles je le dis
c'est de notre faute aussi
c'est notre faute aussi si gill est
devenu comme ça c'est clair qu'ils
avaient beaucoup de personnes qui
avaient du mal à endosser aussi le rôle
de contradicteur et qui n'étaient pas
des contradicteurs parce que ici on joue
pas de rôle et je vais pas dire à
jean-michel toi tube est d'accord que tu
m'aides pas d'accord c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe les réunions et gilles
tandis quele nature il a il est allé un
petit peu trop parce que personne
n'était dans la dans la contradiction et
c'est vrai que le pauvre il a pris
beaucoup de coups pour les autres os
italien et qu'à la fin et
téléspectateurs sont ni il devait un peu
saoulant je dis la vérité je te dis tout
un gilles chevalier ils font
moi je voulais le mettre tous les jours
c'est vraiment pas elles mêmes les
équipes et un moment où on m'a dit
gilles ce qu'il faut pas un petit peu le
laisser se reposer et après leur faire
revenir dans tpm politique je te
lâcherai jamais oui
j'aimerais vraiment vraiment que moi
aussi tu reviennes dans l'émission bien
entendu et j'espère voilà que tu sera de
retour ben on est quel jour en six mois
et voilà on est mardi et ben si tu veux
revenir demain mais c'est un plaisir
alors on va voir d'abord sa réponse les
téléspectateurs voient la regarder oui
battue
[Applaudissements]